When we move to a signal,
which is now of course pulsed or
flutter shuttered like this,
we might have a signal like this.
Of course, the output we know is
convolution of this to this one,
and this is also a sinc function.
And of course,
the big thing here is it is actually
preserving all of the high frequencies.
It's not going down into
the low frequencies.
By basically being able to do this,
we actually now are able to get rid of
modeling all of the low frequencies and
high frequencies are there.
And this is my sinc function.
Again, I would get this by trying to
compute the discrete Fourier transform
of an image in this process.
Recall again, that convolution has a lot
to do with Fourier transforms, when we
looked at all of our signal processing
stuff in one of the earlier lectures.
Here are the two signals
next to each other.
Full open shutter,
sinc function looks like this.
And of course, our flutter shutter,
or a pulse shutter like this,
the since function looks like this,
never gets to some of the low
frequencies always basically.
And again you can see this that
there is a lot more low frequency
information here.
And because of the sharp lines and
stuff like that,
here we are actually seeing a lot
more of the high frequencies.
Simply, again, we flutter shuttered or
pulsed our sense,
our, our shutter to be
able to get this image.
We are interest in, of course,
is the inversion, right?
We are trying to invert this, being able
to go from this to an original image.
Of course, we can do this by
doing inverse Fourier transforms.
And again, in this case, we can now look
at the inverse filters for doing these
types of things, and of course we look
at the two different sine functions.
The thing that is, and this is something
I'm going to refer you to back
to some of the literature
on signal processing.
This kind of a filter is unstable, while
a signal like this is much more stable
because again it's only kind
of capturing the high or
low frequencies in this instance.
And we can represent this much better to
be able to kind of do the inversion to
compute our signals.
And that's the basic idea here
is that trying to do an inverse
discrete Fourier transform, this kind
actually would be much more suitable for
our reconstruction.
Let's look at the examples.
In this case I'm going to basically
show short exposure, long exposure and
coded exposure.
For a long, short exposure,
of course, no light.
We get a ray thing, but
of course we get a nice, crisp image.
Long exposure,
we get a lot of blurriness.
Coded exposure we get
blurriness with a lot more
high frequency information still there.
And of course, we can de-blur this using
the approach I kind of talked about, and
this is what we would get,
much crisper image.
If we were to de-blurring this with
a variety of different approaches,
we might still get some incompleteness.
But in this case by doing it the method
I was doing with discrete Fourier
transforms and stuff like that,
we will get more bars.
By the way, just to compare, this is the
ground truth image that we would have
had if we actually had
captured it correctly.
And this one looks pretty good.
There's a little bit of noise, and
a little bit of banding going on, but
much better than this.
And that's the basic idea of
this flutter shutter camera.
Being able to kind of use this knowledge
to be able to now reconstruct an image
that knows how the variations happen.
Again, we know the code,
we know the output, we can deconvolve
with the knowledge itself to help us
figure out how to actually generate
a reconstruction that's much more true
to what the original image would be.
Same idea as what we looked at for
coded aperture, except this time
of course it's a coded shutter.
Let's see some examples produced
by these authors and their paper.
Here is an example using this camera
here, of basically looking at a car.
Of course, if this car is moving fast,
you cannot actually see
the license plate, which is here.
But, of course, if we had a flutter
shutter camera, you should be able to
reconstruct from this and
actually get the license plate number.
Another example of the same thing again,
somebody says I want more detail here.
This is the original image, but
if I had a flutter shutter camera,
I should be able to generate more.
Another example with the cars again,
this is the orig image, image.
Let's just focus in in there.
And actually,
the whole car image can be regenerated.
And if you notice, we can actually
now start looking up, and
start even reading some of
the numbers and additional detail.
Another input image, we can
rectify the cropped image here and
again create a de-blurred result,
much more crisper.